That's not a fair question. They're both awesome.
Curry. We saw him in the last series. Kid's clutch.
LeBron James, definitely. I feel like LeBron deserves it.
I love the matchup. I think they're both great players...
...but I think Steph's got more heart.
LeBron is just an animal. He's like nine feet tall and extraordinarily powerful,...
...so I feel that I have to go with LeBron.
I think they call him "The King" or something.
Curry all the way. He has all the talent.
I think that makes him a perfect Warrior.
LeBron James.
Steph Curry.
I just personally believe that the Warriors are overrated as an entire team...
...and that they're gonna choke this year to a Cavs team that's fully healthy.
No, Steph Curry is a freaking genius.
Overrated.
Two-time MVP.
His three-pointers are phenomenal. Go Curry.
So many people are so invested in Steph Curry that like,...
...if he doesn't win, I will feel so bad about that.